ali reza's rise to number two in the
world rankings and 2 800 at such a young
age is matched only by magnus carlson in
the modern era in fact ali reza will
have two opportunities in 2023 and in
2025 to become the youngest world chess
champion of all time
he has honed his skills in online chess
playing tens of thousands of games on
chess.com and in this video we are going
to show you five of our favorite
brilliant moves that he's played on our
site
our first brilliant move comes from a
bullet game against the speed demon
andrew tang in this position ali reza
has just played the excellent knight to
h5 inducing the response rook to g8 this
move does look a little bit awkward and
in general black's development seems a
bit awkward but things shouldn't be too
bad right after all the queens are off
the board black has some development and
the position is symmetrical
however things are very very bad
and that is because ali reza now plays
the bomb bishop 2
h6 a crushing and visually striking move
the immediate threat is simply to
capture on g7 and the capture of g7 will
wreck the black position
of course the critical question is can
black capture the bishop on h6 well not
safely as happens in the game we get
pawn captures h6 but now knight to f6
check the g pawn has been pulled away
from the defense of this critical square
knight to f6 check is a fork hitting the
king and the rook and of course the
bishop cannot capture because of the pin
on the e file
the king steps over to f8 which is the
only way to continue to defend the rook
on g8 but now knight takes g8 and the
king cannot capture because of rook
takes e7 ali reza is stealing an
exchange and wrecking the black position
however there is one try left trapping
the knight on g8 the knight is
threatening of course to capture this
bishop and to get out by capturing the
pawn at h6 so bishop to g5 is the only
sensible move defending against both
threats
in this position though simply h4
attacking the bishop and if the bishop
goes to d2 then it can simply be
attacked again with rook to e2 and in
fact there are a number of winning moves
the knight will not be trapped over here
ali reza is getting the knight out of
there and after h4 bishop takes h4 he
simply played knight takes h6 both
bishops are hanging and in this position
on move 21 grandmaster tang resigned
our next example features another
visually striking move in the opening
alireza has just played queen takes b7
and black defended with rook c8 holding
the knight on c6
it's very very clear that black's
position is bad the king is stuck in the
middle of the board and you have
basically a whole king side to develop
before you can castle
simple developing moves are good very
strong in fact but ali reza is sharp
eyed and finds a chance to finish the
game on the spot it is the move knight
to d6 check
another brilliant move that seems to
advance the knight to a square where
there's everything defending
the pawn on the e file and the queen on
d8 however if the pawn captures then
there is queen captures on f7 with a
typical scholar's mate
and in the game the queen does capture
you have no other legal move
but now you have queen captures on c8
check stealing an exchange and just
crushing the black position black did
play this and try to resist but alireza
easily won the game
ali reza and eric hansen have played
many battles on chess.com and both
players have landed some beautiful shots
in this game though it is ali reza who
gets the upper hand after many twists
and turns here he plays the shocking
rook to d5
an incredible interference sacrifice yet
again alireza is playing a piece to a
square that seems to be impregnably
defended in this case d5 is held by the
pawn by the bishop and by the rook but
ali reza's point is not to sacrifice one
rook but to sacrifice two rooks and
after pawn takes d5 he would do so with
rook takes g5 which forces mate for
example pawn takes queen takes and there
is mate on g7
so
after rook d5 eric ignores the rook here
to gain time to defend and to make sure
he holds his rook on c5 which does
defend along the fifth rank he plays
king h7 and ali reza is not to be
deterred he continues to sacrifice rooks
with rook g takes g5 a winning sacrifice
but after pawn takes g5
and now queen takes g5 rook g8 alireza
does not play the correct move
that is knight to g7 this move threatens
queen to h5 with checkmate and eric can
only give up a lot of material to try to
hold the game but it is a losing
position
however there is a case of mutual
hallucination alireza plays queen h4
and eric finds the accurate defense rook
to g6
but then after knight to f4 check it
seems both players missed that rook h6
was possible and winning for black
so actually played is king g8 and
there's another small tactic
knight takes g6 pawn takes g6 and
alireza has the final stinging blow f7
check a discovery that wins the queen on
d8 and wins the game on the spot
there may be no more titanic rivalry on
chess.com than hikaru nakamura versus
alireza ferrugia and we look forward to
many more great battles between these
two players we are going to finish this
video with two excellent and beautiful
attacks for molly reza first in this
position it's clear that alireza has
good compensation for the exchange with
an inconveniently placed king on f3 and
an excellent square on e4 for the knight
however it certainly doesn't seem that
black should be winning but let's note a
key tactical detail if alireza could he
would play the move queen captures his
own knight on f6 this would be czech and
would pick up the rook on b2 with an
overwhelming positional advantage
since he can't play that move he can at
least sacrifice the knight to gain
access to the f6 square and he does so
with the beautiful move
knight to g4
this empty square knight sacrifice is
very very strong
there are many threats emerging here
including knight to e5 with check simply
knight takes e3 and also various checks
along the f file the critical point is
that the knight cannot be captured
because after king takes g4 queen to e6
check
there's no way to avoid placing the kink
on a square where it can be checked by
the queen and then the rook on b2 falls
with more material to fall soon after
so after knight to g4 hikaru actually
plays the move queen to d4 but then you
simply have knight takes e3 now hikaru
is still up in exchange but it really
doesn't matter
the knight is amazingly placed here on
e3 it covers g2 it covers g4 so the
threat of check along the f file is
crushing queen h4 is played and alireza
patiently plays queen to e5 attacking
the rook and preparing a devastating
check right here in fact hikaru saw no
reason to continue and resigned in this
position
our final example has been deemed an
immortal blitz game by none other than a
god mature and who are we to question
that assessment however this is also the
only example that did not receive a
brilliant annotation from our algorithm
possibly for correct reasons but i think
once you see this example you will agree
that there is a ton of brilliance in
reza's attack even if the engine can
narrowly refute the idea
in this position the bishop on b6 is in
a lot of trouble so alireza decides to
sacrifice it with pawn to d5 this is
really the only try in the position
because the black position is crumbling
unless the attack succeeds
now we get pawn takes b6 so hicaro is up
a bishop in this position and knight
takes g2
again whether or not this move works it
is brilliant because it is the only move
that can pose a real challenge to hikaru
in this position
after knight takes g2 the critical
question is can hecaro accept the
sacrifice
it's certainly scary but the answer is
yes he can take the knight and after
king takes g2 there's queen g6 check
king h1 and queen e4 with a very awkward
pin
in fact hikaru does have to give back a
piece here but he can do so because he's
up two of them after rook g1 queen
captures on f3 with check and then rook
to g2
only white should win in this position
however this is not the way the game
continues
after knight captures g2 hikaru tries a
different move
knight to e5 a move that tries to
totally interrupt the black attack
and now in this position the algorithm
actually suggests that the next move is
a missed win but that really doesn't
seem an entirely fair assessment
alireza plays
rook takes e5
an insane sacrifice
he's obviously leaving the knight
hanging on g2 he's sacrificing his rook
for this knight and most importantly of
all he is sacrificing the rook on a8
with check
now
it is possible to defend as white but
only to hold a draw and only with some
crazy moves
however more accurate than rook takes e5
but containing kind of the same ideas is
knight to f4
also brilliant
and this move intends rook takes e5 in
even better circumstances it also allows
some time for defense and is less
forcing though
the most natural seeming defense is king
h1 preparing rook g1 and rook g2 and it
would take an absolute genius or
computer engine with a lot of time to
think to figure out that in this
position white's defense does not hold
you can play rook takes e5 which does
again
brilliantly sacrifice the rook on 8 with
check
and here after rook g1 you have rook h5
threatening rook takes h2 and then queen
h4 checked with mate but now rook to g4
if rook g2 by the way you're just a
little bit too passive you can't give
back material successfully here
knight takes g2 king takes g2 you're
only down a bishop here and the attack
is decisive after queen g6 check
but
more natural is rook g4 so this doesn't
work anymore because you're not able to
go to h4 with check from the queen
so rook g4 queen f5 hitting this rook
and eyeing this square
rook over to g1 queen to e4 with check
rook to g2 which does utilize this pin
right here so you can't capture with
knight takes g2
and in this position the attack is
decisive after the patient rook g5
there's simply no way to hold this pin
after for example queen to c8 trying to
defend this you just cut off that with
pawn to f5
and here you're still down a rook but
you're winning it's really remarkable
and this is not the only line there are
other tries for white as well but in all
lines black does win the game
in the game though instead of playing
knight f4 immediately alireza tries rook
takes e5
and now here we have queen takes a8 with
check which is actually very similar to
capturing on e5 right away but queen
takes a8 check is of course more natural
pick up a rook with check if you can't
hold it then you can't hold it but
you've got to try taking the rook with
check
king h7
and now there is an insane defense
it is the move pawn to f4
this move doesn't capture the rook but
threatens to capture it with two
different pawns and most importantly it
does not allow the rook to go to g5
the attack is still very strong for
black and once again only a computer
could properly assess this but the
accurate assessment is that it's a draw
after knight takes f4 and other lines we
have pawn captures on e5 and the queen
and knight are able to hold a perpetual
check but not deliver victory after
queen g6 check king f2 of course you
can't go this way because this is mate
so now queen g2 check and again there
are mates in the position but after king
e3 there's nothing better than queen to
e4 check
the king must step back because here
there are again mates after king to d2
queen check and you either have a knight
to e2 or queen to e2 with checkmate
but after king f2 this is a draw by
perpetual an insane line
however hikaru does not find the
incredible defense pawn to f4 really
what human would it would be great
reason to check uh any player
for use of an engine if they could play
f4 in this position instead after pawn
takes e5 white is up two rooks but now
queen to f3 there's simply the idea of
knight out of g2 and queen to g2
checkmate and in fact it's a decisive
idea there's nothing better for white
than to give back the queen with queen
captures d5 which is what hikara does
but now you have queen captures on d5
rook 81
and the very patient and accurate queen
to f3 making sure there's no relief and
all of the threats are renewed
rook up to d3 giving back a rook but
after queen takes d3 there's not even
time here to capture the the knight on
g2 i mean you can do it but then this
falls here instead icaru tries a
slightly trickier move pawn takes c7 so
he's threatening promotion down here but
promotion is not enough the final move
in the game is knight to f4 and the idea
is to allow a new queen white will again
be up a rook but you have queen to f3
intending queen to g2 with checkmate
you're also threatening queen to g6 and
the queen will again make it to g2 there
are a number of tries for white but it
is in fact mate in five and you can test
it for yourself a really stunning
victory by ali reza
if you want to see more brilliant moves
by players such as hikaru nakamura then
simply click on the videos that are
popping up on your feed as i speak